and I think there's an expound upon and
the importance of them
so share with me if I have
brain issues
and I don't like fish I'm not eating
fish which is not true
essential fatty acids
if I'm deficient in them
is that going to cause or be part of the
underlying cause
yes and of course you use the correct
term essential fatty acids
um a lot of people think that
they require oils as a requirement to
their diet
and it's very very bad
um to think that oils are totally
different than essential fatty acids
essential fatty acids are oily but
they're they're not oils okay
um we're talking about the bad things
especially if you know they've been in a
bottle or a can
for days weeks or months
and you heat them up in cooking we're
talking about corn oil soy Oil we're
talking about
olive oil we're talking about all the
vegetables you can think of okay one of
the worst ones are peanut oil because
they grow on the ground okay most other
oils are from almost all other oils or
in seeds and things that grow on top of
the ground or in trees and nuts and that
kind of thing
um when you're talking about peanuts
they grow in the ground and they're
susceptible
very commonly to an infection
infestation of a fungus called
aspergillus flavus
and estrogelous flavors
um very frequently I'll say it that way
very frequently
gets
contaminated with his astragalus flavus
over the penis get contaminated with
them okay and the aspergillus slaves
produces a
um
what a product
called aflatoxin
okay an aflatoxin produces liver cancer
and one of the things I used to see on
the autopsy table was you know sort of
middle-aged men middle-aged women
uh on the autopsy table was a liver
cancer that had gone to their lungs and
their brain and and so forth but why
were these young people what was the
cause of liver cancer well it turns out
it's the amphotoxin
from peanuts in order to people get
aflatoxin from peanuts well every Friday
they get their paycheck they'd all run
to the bar with their buddies and things
and be drinking beer or whiskey or
whatever it was
and the bartenders would give them free
peanuts
to entice them to come there and stay
for a couple of hours
and run the bill up a little bit
and these free peanuts were infested
with aflatoxin and caused liver cancer
and they go to the doctor and say oh you
have liver cancer you drink alcohol well
yeah every Friday we drink beer well
there you go it wasn't the alcohol and
the beer that caused the liver cancer it
was the aflatoxin in the peanuts
peanut butter peanut ice cream
okay everything was made with peanuts is
very dangerous
so Dr Wallach I want to I want to add to
that because
there's a lot of people that get liver
cancer that don't drink
they don't eat well they were told
peanuts were good for them that they're
a good protein source
so and they're cooking peanut oil
and then yeah of course
peanuts being promoted as something
that's good and healthy and then you
correlate that peanut oil being good and
healthy and in all actuality you've
proven that it is totally false and
incorrect yet it was promoted as being
healthy like so many other things that
we have learned Dr Wallach yes okay now
with all that said
um
the thing you have to appreciate
essential fatty acids are totally a
different story okay and of course
um the essential fatty acids required
for every cell in your body regardless
of what type of tissue or organ it is or
system you're in
um essential fatty acids we have
the efas okay
which primarily come from seeds then we
have the EFA pluses which come from fish
okay fish livers
and they're required to manage and
protect and help the function of the
cell wall of every cell in the body also
they work on the in inside all the
chemical reaction is going on inside
cells
require efas and EFA pluses okay
hormones
and your brain your spinal cord
contain an enormous amount of efas okay
and EFA pluses
and so when you think about
vegetable oils
don't think about olive oil unless you
have an olive tree and you're plucking
that twig off the tree and you're eating
the olives right off that little twig
that's fine
when you're eating olive oil there's
been in a
um
bottle or can
for weeks or months or years in a store
or Warehouse sometimes being 150 degrees
in the summertime
and then you open up that body you open
up that can
and you use that olive oil in your salad
or cooking oh my gosh it's already
oxidized and turned into trans fats
heterocyclic amines and filaments but
you're the cause of plugging of your
arteries it wasn't cholesterol the
plagiar arteries
is the oxidized vegetable oils
because plaque in the arteries okay now
your brain is 25 cholesterol your spinal
cord is 25 cholesterol male hormones and
female hormones are 95 cholesterol
and so that's why we came up with I-26
and it comes in powder it comes in
capsules and it comes in chewable little
flat platelets or I don't know if you
call them disc maybe a half a millimeter
thick in the diameter of a quarter okay
and I ate two two of those at lunch time
maybe three sometimes at lunch time and
it says right on the bottle
gives you 25 of your daily requirement
of cholesterol now I think this is the
only product in the market in the world
that talks about
cholesterol requirements
okay
and when you see an MRI of your brain
and they say oh my you're demyelinating
that's why you're having all this
tingling and numbness and pain in your
fingers and toes and your back and your
face and everything because your your
brain is demyelinating well myelin is
the white matter of the brain and myelin
is 100 cholesterol
if you're avoiding cholesterol you
cannot maintain that myelin the white
man or the brain you wind up with all
these
myelin deficiency problems short
circuiting and that causes all these
weird peripheral neuropathies and you
name it okay chiropractors are happy
um orthopedic surgeons are happy
your medical doctor is happy your
insurance company is unhappy because
they have to pay for everything okay and
so it's worth
um getting this book was my newest one
the wallet Revolution
covers a 75-year journey from the time I
was I don't know five or six years old
until now okay
no thank you thank you and we also have
the book it's all in your head covers 37
different diseases that are caused by
osteoporosis of the skull
we have
the book immortality we spent a
five-year project
on this immortality project where we
visited all these
these people all around the world who
live long healthful lives and what it is
they did differently it's what they ate
what they didn't eat what grew were they
surrounded by volcanoes giving them
ashes for their Gardens okay because
until electricity came and all that
story about electricity is in the book
Hell's Kitchen
there you go Hell's Kitchen and Hell's
Kitchen
cover this is probably one of the
biggest stories in the history of
humanity since God okay okay and because
what happened was
um for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years we use wood ashes and
coal ashes as fertilizer for our Gardens
the spice in our foods and what ashes
and coal ashes are 95 percent by weight
minerals and two or three percent by
weight carbon
and that's where we were getting our
minerals by using them as a spice and
also using them as fertilizer in the
garden so every time you'd eat something
grown in the garden it was fertilized
with the wood acid coal ashes are
getting those minerals and bottomland
would flood every year when the flood
waters would recede Farmers would plow
in that silt that came from the
mountains when the when the ice and
Glaciers would melt and the volcanoes
would hit and all that kind of stuff
well three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 on Pearl
Street in New York City in the platform
located construction of Brooklyn Bridge
all hell broke loose just like what goes
on in that District in New York City
they call it Hell's Kitchen that's why
we called the book Hell's Kitchen the
story Hell's Kitchen because certainly
now
our source of nutritional metals that we
had had for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years went away it's almost
like overnight
flip to switch and all these nutrients
went away
and doctors didn't appreciate that and
so they just said well you know you have
a genetic disease because if you're
discovering genetics you have an
autoimmune disease your body's attacking
itself because they didn't know and they
didn't want to say they didn't know
but we were getting all these diseases
because we didn't have the nutrients
anymore
and plants do not make minerals it over
it plants do not make minerals plants
make vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids but and they make
as I said the fatty acids the essential
fatty acids is the euphz if he pluses
okay
um plants do not make minerals
nutritional minerals like calcium and
zinc and copper and selenium and
um you name it you know every kind of
murmuring think of
um
is
let's see here what should I say is in
veins like gold and silver does not if
they do not occur in uniform blankets
around the crust of the earth and that's
why you can be eating the same
um uh which they say here era what a
identical twin of somebody and they're
living 50 miles away different County or
different country or something like that
a different state and they're eating the
same recipes you are cause grandma
passed them down to y'all
but they don't have any problems
and you have every disease you can think
of
and actually well you know you're
getting old you're 50 years old you got
to think about it you're going to get
all these diseases no it's because
you're missing these nutrients and your
twin okay are your spouse or whatever is
living in a different city or state or
County or country and they're getting
the minerals and they don't have the
problems
and so you got to get with it okay and
this is why we came up with our Sports
rank Rebound with with 100 nutrients at
75 minerals and
25 vitamins amino acids
and we have in sticks there's 30 sticks
in a box under a nutrients in here okay
and then we have the cancer there's 36
servings in a canister okay
36 servings in here a little scoop okay
and then we have the cans and the cans
are 12 ounces there's 12 cans in a in a
uh
box okay
12 cans in a box and but
12 cans in a case in a case in a box
case yeah okay and so I pop them at
night before bedtime I pop two of them
at night before bed put them in the
refrigerator so they're off gas they're
flat in the morning I drink one with
breakfast and drink one at lunch or
maybe at two o'clock or something like
that
and I'm getting my 100 nutrients now
that happens because I'm also getting
the healthy brain and heart pack twice a
day so I'm getting my 100 nutrients
and then I snack and stuff like that and
another nutrients
well guess what duh I'm getting at least
my 100 nutrients four to six times a day
Pam what's going on if I'm taking extra
if I'm taking extra
um rebound or I'm throwing in another
because I'm staying up another couple
hours late driving at night or something
like that and throwing another uh dose
of the healthy brain and heart pack I'm
getting four or five or six doses of the
hundred nutrients a day
how many doses a day are you getting of
100 nutrients okay huh
at least three let's see you're you what
you do for your rebound takes too much
work I just put two scoops in my 32
ounce cup Dr while like stir it with my
stock and drink it
well there you go I mean it's easier and
you get more servings in the canister
well that's that's right yeah well
that's what we came up with that so you
have your choice your options let's see
what we wanted to do is compete with the
other sports drinks and energy drinks
many of them only have one mineral like
magnesium and so it's one of those
things where
and they're carbonated and the kids
especially like the carbonation and once
they come with us we educate them to say
you know you really need to get the
carbonation out of your life because it
will interrupt the ability to utilize
the nutrients and so forth you'll be
better in your teams you'll you'll
perform better in your sports you'll
perform better in the classroom you'll
live longer and so we slowly teach all
these kids to remove the carbonation
from their life but if we
um which I say if we beat them up on
carbonation they wouldn't come to us
come on I love my carbonation I have to
have my carbonation they love it okay
because you know
let's get back to the essential fatty
acids because that's what's going to
help make our kiddos even smarter and
better also Dr Wallach now you had
mentioned
um hormones and needing cholesterol like
hormones also need essential fatty acids
also right
they need the essential patties that's
correct and of course the I-26 has the
um cholesterol in it okay and of course
also the efas and EFA pluses we have the
pro cardio effects those three things I
take those three also because they give
you the essential fatty acids
in the efas the fa pluses all right it's
one of those things where it's kind of
like
um you have to have all forms of these
things
to make sure that you're providing each
cell each tissue each system in your
body with what it wants or prefers don't
make it work to change something into
what it wants so if you give it what it
wants you will very very quickly
especially if you have problems like
arthritis have a pressure diabetes or
it's uh obviously approaches asthma oh I
love getting rid of asthma in kids in
two weeks you know and they've had
asthma almost their whole life it's
essential fatty acid deficiencies cause
asthma and they got to get rid of and
the parents if they're breastfeeding
them the mom they got to get rid of the
um
all the bad stuff in their diet okay
including you know these things that
interfere with absorption and you know
we're talking about everything from
carbonated drinks to fried foods
processed meats and all that kind of
stuff gotta go so they can absorb these
nutrients you can't depend on them being
in the food
okay plants or food plants are crop
plants
only need three minerals
NPK nitrogen phosphor potassium now do
you think
that the average farmer is going to put
90 essential nutrients into Farmland
okay or maybe a couple hundred bucks an
acre uh well if they don't realize that
that's what the body needs if they're
just growing it they're growing it
because of the need for the
that staple
and not so much
what's going into the nutrition part of
it that's so important
I mean we can't expect one person to
know anything and everything about what
they're doing and the effect that it has
on
the final
customer yeah the value of the product
right so there's there's a lot well just
growing a ton of beets doesn't mean
anything but it does to their pocket but
if it all it doesn't have all the
nutrients in it those beets the end
point to the customers buys those beats
is not getting the best deal
so it's an empty ton
there you go very good empty gun
empty ton tea o n but
so so back to your essential fatty acids
and folks if you're not familiar with
essential fatty acids have you ever
heard about omega-3s omega-6s omega-9s
those are essential fatty acids which
you can find in different foods you can
find and and where they're promoted but
most Dr Wallach are in those vegetable
oils like sunflower canola olives
soybean avocado Palm coconut but folks
when you take something out of its
natural state and you remove
the preservatives the things that hold
it keep that molecule stable
it oxidizes it converts and then
especially when you add Heat
oh my goodness it's toxic within the
body it's putting all those free
radicals into the body that attack the
cells
and oil think about it
it's a liquid
goes in the mouth
under the tongue is where the vessels
are the closest to the surface so things
are getting absorbed real quick into the
bloodstream
and what is close to the mouth your eyes
your brain and then you go into the
lungs and the Heart all those things are
being affected by those free radicals
and toxins that are getting into your
system
so
making sure that you're picking a
quality
EFA a quality essential fatty acid Dr
Wallach you've mentioned this before the
process that our essential fatty acids
or youngevity is essential fatty acids
go through
that prevents them from being exposed to
oxygen because that oxygen oxidates them
yes so we do everything in a nitrogen
environment even the capsules the soft
shell capsules that we put our efas and
EFA pluses into which are the efas and
if a plus is okay
um the um it's in a nitrogen environment
we blow nitrogen through those capsules
before we put the efas and Fa pluses in
them then we seal them then we put those
capsules into the bottle if a pluses and
the pro priority FX
and we then blow the nitrogen through
the bottle and then before we seal it
and so we're protecting those Omega-3s
and omegas
until you open the bottle now if you eat
them at the rate in which you're
supposed to eat them you know it'll be
depending on your body weight and
everything maybe two to four weeks a
bottle will last you okay and so it's
one of those things where
um you pay wholesale you become a you
know an official member you'll pay
wholesale prices you get on auto ship I
will pay the shipping
I mean come on uh and even even if
you're paying
um the
um
you know the wholesale prices if you are
a
um what should I say a official
representative okay with us
you know you've joined officially as a
representative
guess what in your little business plan
you can say your business is going to
pay for your health care and your
nutritional supplements and so that all
becomes tax deductible
and so you know I'm spending several
hundred dollars a month on my
supplements but they're all tax
deductible because in my business plan I
said that my business has to pay for my
health care my health insurance anything
that I need to have prescriptions and so
forth that aren't paid for by insurance
and any energy drinks and uh specials
dietary foods that are safe and
everything all that becomes tax
deductible okay because you put in your
business plan
so I want to make a little bit of
clarity because Dr Wallach you you get
your paycheck and your income from the
sale of your books so he's talking in
general as an associate as a distributor
with the youngevity company where having
your supplements as part of your health
care
can be taxed right off
also for us we have to be products of
the product Dr Wall like we can't just
promote something and not have our own
personal experience with it
and in order to earn our income and earn
our commissions we have to have our own
personal order which that in itself is
part of the direct selling association's
requirement and so we can write off our
personal orders because they're part of
our overhead they're required to earn
our commission
so I think it's pretty awesome that you
know there's there's things that are
built in to help keep Integrity of the
associates so that it's not just
somebody saying okay I'm going to
promote this product never tried the
product in their life but they do need
to have their own personal order in
order to get their commissions so that
they can honestly say when somebody asks
them well what do you take and what has
it done for you
well let me tell you
that story of what it's done for me has
gotten me to where I'm at
and I'm enjoying life I'm looking
forward to the future I don't mind
those birthdays that keep raking up
another number
I I'm I don't mind it at all so I'm
looking forward to the future I'm
looking forward to to Growing Old but
I'm growing younger Dr Wallach because
my cells are being more nourished
and creating healthier and healthier
cells
so well you're a very good example
because you have a lot of health issues
and I think most of them are gone now
and so yeah
I I've had an injury since getting on
the products that that's my only
lingering thing that I'm that I'm still
working through but I'll tell you what
if it wasn't for the nutrition that fall
down the stairs I probably would have
broke something
hmm
but I didn't so
I'll take it and I and I love having you
know the the natural things that I can
do that help to relieve the inflammation
relieve pain and I know that the
nutritioner is in there working
so Dr well we want to go back to rebound
because somebody on YouTube has a
question about rebound and folks if you
are watching us welcome if you joined us
here just recently we especially want to
welcome you welcome you and say thank
you for joining us here in this hour of
empowering information that allows you
to go from just surviving to thriving
when you implement what we talk about in
this program
so there's a question Congress has
sponsored the sponsored by the American
Heart Association
and they are promoting
defibrillators to save athletes with
their AED Bill do you think promoting
rebound would be helpful
well yes of course when you when when
athletes die from a
um hypertrophy cardiopathy heart attack
okay
um I'm autopsied lots of them
unfortunately and it's one of those
things where
um
this is the same thing that causes the
childhood disease okay
that um was blamed on the mother laying
on the babies
okay SIDS sediment death syndrome the
mothers are laying on the babies and
suffocating the babies doctors said that
for years and years and years and years
and years and years until I proved it
was caused by nutritional deficiency of
a single mineral
okay
um our great attorney jonathanie Moore
and I we sued the FDA eight times in
federal court to get those nutrients put
into a baby frogs like Enfamil and
Similac and so forth and they weren't in
there because we had tried for over 20
years to get those minerals into the
baby formulas and pediatricians kept
saying no those are poisonous you can't
put that in the baby formulas and blah
blah blah
and so finally we prevailed in federal
court
and within 90 days sediment death
syndrome stopped
okay also the the disease must just be
went away
suddenly the disease since the fibrosis
went away because all three of them are
caused by deficiency of the same
nutrients
okay and so you think about we got rid
of mustard is free now Jerry Lewis thank
God knew before he died and when he
brought them the story about masjisfy
how he we and of course he had
interviewed doctors and families and
patients and everything and he was
convinced we were correct
he took that on September 4th
2011. okay to the Massachusetts
Association they're going to have a big
Telethon that weekend on Saturday oh and
Sunday uh the fourth and fifth
and of course every having a business
meeting that Saturday night he shared
the story with him they summarily fired
him they fired Jerry Lewis after he had
raised 2.6 billion dollars over 46 years
he was telling son they shut down the
Telethon for the next day
and they put a gag order on him so he
couldn't tell the story
publicly okay you know that's really
made me reconsider Dr well like
supporting these different organizations
that are raising money for research
especially with the knowledge that I
have now based on your books your
research your lectures that have already
found the underlying causes of these
conditions and you take that underlying
cause away you fortify the body with the
nutrition which goes right along to this
next message that comes up that says
that Congress promote
the use of supplementation being paid by
our insurance companies
it just it makes it's it's too simple as
what it is Dr Wallach and it doesn't
make the big guys the money but hey
let's invite those big guys to join us
and help promote a healthier world
instead of Sick management we should be
in Wellness management that's correct
it's better to prevent things that's why
you put all in the car and brake fluid
transmission fluid antifreeze you put
those things in the car before the
engine burns up before the car crashes
and everything and it's a lot cheaper a
lot more comfortable for the drivers
okay
and we need to do it more than just when
I get our tax
income tax return folks it's an all year
thing it's maintenance
it's life
that's right just incorporate it into
your life
and life would be so much better it
worked for me
well Dr Wallach we do have some hands up
here with us in the Pro in the then the
zoom we think all of our listeners out
there on the live stream and YouTube and
Rumble and the communications that
they're sitting back and forth and folks
if you're hearing this message and you
want to join us in this crusade to
promote Wellness management not sick
management remote Wellness management
anything and everything that somebody
else does is making somebody money why
not take and put money in your own
pocket doing something that is promoting
life promoting Wellness promoting
stronger communities and it's not just
promoting them physically but when the
physical body is functioning properly so
is the mental capacity of the
individuals of the communities
and
I truly believe Dr Wallach that we can
cut mental illness
drastically yes we cut mental illness we
also cut crime rates down
cause and effect I like that cause and
effect you know unlike you talk about
the dams and damning off the whole
mineral Supply and being deposited which
reduces the minerals in our food well
let's focus on re-fortifying the bodies
giving the bodies what they need
and mamas and daddies before those
babies are born which then makes
healthier babies
and yes it's going to affect the
pocketbooks
of the big guys
but what's more important your health or
somebody's pocketbook
for me it's my health I did what it took
Dr Wally to get the products that I
needed to take
and it paid off and now I'm able to do
it for others and help others get what
they need and the information which
information is knowledge that cannot be
taken away from you
so well said okay I'm off my soapbox I'm
off myself a plus
thank you Dr Wallach um let's go to
Kathy Kathy welcome back go ahead and
unmute yourself
can you unmute Kathy
all right well she's working on getting
unmuted Dr Wallach I have lots of
questions over here that have come in
from people that have signed up for our
newsletter and also who have said yeah
just through just a minute Kathy let me
finish this thought
um through the website you can go to our
website use that contact us and this is
for people who have never spoken to
anybody about youngevity about the
products that's what our website is
there for when it comes to the store and
the contact us the information
uses a resource share it but we want to
make sure that the person that shared
the information
has you coming back to them
to continue and get the products and
build a business
so
first question I have here Dr Wallach
this sweet lady she's 89 years old
120 pounds
five foot four
she has a history of tuberculosis in her
right hip and at the age of four uh the
surgeon stiffened the hip which then
resulted in the right leg being three
inches shorter than the left leg and
about 10 years ago she pain started and
she's on no medications so Dr Wallach
what would you recommend for
this sweet dear lady Jessica
okay well Jessica needs to get rid of
all the bad foods okay it's never too
late to get off all the bad foods and
we're talking about fried foods air
frying deep frying
um pan frying absolutely no oils no oils
um and uh actually uh no
um let's see here no gluten no wheat
nobody rhinos there are no such things
as gluten-free oats gluten and oats is
called gliadin still gluten and then no
buckwheat there's no gluten in but wheat
but buckwheat does have fago pirates in
them f-a-g-o-pyrians which are worse
than gluten they kill the intestinal
lining so you can't absorb nutrition and
then
um no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the carbonated soft drinks diet drinks
are no good and the carbonated water is
no good because it neutralizes your
stomach acid so you cannot absorb
minerals and digest food
so now with all that then at 120 pounds
I wanted to have one healthy brain and
heart pack per month and half of those
everything twice a day in order to get
two bottles a month it's a lot don't
want to get two bottles a month so the
MSM shouldn't take three of breakfast
sweet lunch for dinner and they're going
to support and promote Mains repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between invertebrate bone
makes bone itself I also wanted to have
the collagen peptides the two of the
canisters so you take a scoop of their
morning drink and scoop of their evening
drink I also want her to take vitamin D3
through those twice a day
and I also want her to have our I would
see here our I-26 and she can take the
chewables the capsules of the powder in
order to have two doses a day I take my
two doses at lunch time I like the
chewables because it tastes like vanilla
even little kids like them and they're
going to help rebuild the brain and the
spinal cord and the peripheral nerves
and everything with myelin or white
matter in them okay for insulation and
then because she has a history of
tuberculosis I would have her take our
colloidal silver take a proper full of
that under her tongue uh
in the morning a drummerful on the right
side a dropper full on the left side in
the morning before breakfast before
lunch before dinner time and then also
let's um let's see here for pain we do
have the CM cream
and you can apply that topically for um
the CM cream topically on her hip
and
um it'll be one of those she'll get
relief in about 10-15 minutes and it'll
last a couple of hours okay and over
time as she rebuilds those joints
including that hip that's
um
he has the same problem okay where the
cartilage is gone she had an infection
it's tuberculosis in there and it's one
of those things where we're going to
rebuild that hip okay it's going to take
some time because of our age because
it's been that way for a long time
but using the same cream is going to
relieve and prevent an enormous amount
of that can discomfort
now I want to make it clear Dr well like
I mean she's lost three inches in length
of that leg we're not regrowing the leg
no
but what we're doing is we're
strengthening what's there removing the
inflammation that is causing the pain
right that's correct and that's why we
need to have the the pain reliever okay
the same cream because
you know she may gain a half inch of her
leg back she's not going to gain regain
all three inches especially at her age
and so forth but what she needs to do
she may have done this already you know
get these shoes they have shoes that may
have two inch thick three inch thick
soles and heels on them okay
um for walking and so forth that way
they won't be so cumbersome and
dangerous for falling and all that kind
of stuff
yeah help keep the keep the balance so
all right and that's CM cream doctor
well like that was like a lifesaver for
me and it it does it really works you
put a little bit in there I love to mix
some of our essential oils which is the
highest grade of essential oil taking
those Esters those good things out of
plants that have been proven to be
therapeutic for the body and helping in
its Endeavors and journey to be balanced
in and working properly too so let's go
back over to Kathy Kathy can you unmute
quickly
yes I can
all right
I don't know
like what can you criticize maybe water
and tea
um what can you drink besides water and
tea doctor while like besides water tea
of course we got the rebound
I love to add the plant Drive minerals
to my water
yep and of course uh let's see here
um
I think that's the best directions to go
uh people say well what about juice well
juice has a lot of sugar in it okay and
so I'm not big on drinking you know
eight ounce glass of orange juice and
eight ounce glass of grape juice and
eggs grams a glass of apple juice or
anything like that because there's too
much sugar in there okay and so
um I'm not big on those things so I
that's why I like the rebound or rebound
um we have the sticks we have the the
powder and the canister we do have the
cans but I like to pop the tops on the
canvas at night put in the refrigerators
that are flat in the morning
okay okay
exactly I don't know if you can see what
I'm holding up but this has become one
of my new favorite water additives that
I drink throughout the day where I'm
getting a full dose of collagen a full
dose of plant derived minerals and it's
in a great cherry flavor I was talking
with one of our other coaches and he
said his buddy is from the gym and the
people he work with absolutely love the
mineral sticks
so that's a great addition to water as
well and so that you're you're getting
some structure to your water and poor
fighting can you take two or three of
those a day
well I can have two or three doses of
plant Drive minerals and I can have two
or three doses of collagen absolutely
I'm so glad
yes I'm so glad I bought you guys so I
love you so much and
I know I had to change my diet and
I really want to do this because I want
to get up with dialysis and get help get
healthy
okay well Dallas says you need the
ultimate daily plastic tablets ultimate
daily classic tablets now this is an
addition to the other brand hard pack
and MSM and all this other stuff right
but the yeah but the ultimate daily
classic tablets
um let's see how much do you weigh Kathy
100 pounds 100 pounds okay so I'd heavy
I'd heavy get to two bottles a month of
the ultimate daily plastic tablets come
in a glass bottle with a green label
and um started off by taking two three
times a day and then your goal should be
um to take three
oh twice a day and and two once a day
okay but start out with two three times
a day of the ultimate daily classic
tablets and they're going to support
healthy blood pressure but in your case
it also supports healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries and we get
people off the dialysis every day around
the world with that product along oh
goodness I can't wait and a healthy
brain and heart back the old the
ultimate daily classic and the
Hildebrand heart pack ultimate daily
Classics ultimate daily classic is for
the
kidney function and blood pressure okay
and then help you get off of dialysis or
at least reduce or save how many days a
week are you doing dialysis twice three
times five times
twice a week yeah okay now that's that's
an easy one we take people around six
days a week
and they haven't urinated in 10 years
and in two weeks time they're urinating
so they drop them down to three days a
week and then two more weeks are totally
off the dialysis after 10 years and not
urinating in 10 years of being on
dialysis of six days a week we do this
all the time okay and so it's one of
those things where again the medical
assistant was you know supporting
people's requirements for urination and
blood pressure and everything like that
medically
but they weren't doing anything to heal
the body so you they didn't need the
treatment anymore okay we're giving you
what your body needs to repair itself
and so we've been very very successful
at doing this so we're not giving you
just idle Theory this is
this is this is very very
um which I say well documented
that's good what about collagen pet
tanks
no collagen peptides are great okay and
of course it's one of those things where
um I said you need the collagen peptides
go ahead and take a scoop of that with
your morning drink keep it out of scoop
in your evening drink and that's going
to help rebuild cartilage and ligaments
and tendons and artery walls and skin
and uh you know just about everything
that's made out of connective tissue
okay can you put like a smoothie
I'm sorry
okay thank you yes you can mix it in a
smoothie you can mix it in your tea you
can mix it in your coffee the collagen
peptides are amazing because they don't
have any foul smell they don't have a
foul taste they uh dissolve
easily I mean I mix it in my tea I mix
it in my oh my hot chocolate Dr walek
youngevity has some really good hot
chocolate for those even those who are
on keto my favorite hot chocolate that I
mix the collagen in there also
I love our peptides Dr Wallach I love
our mineral sticks and folks if you go
to our website
dailywithdoc.com to do mineral s t x
that's how we're spelling sticks on that
and you'll be able to find the mineral
sticks we have a quick question here I
know we're cutting short on time
um Anthony wants to know if the healthy
brain and heart pack is the same as the
90 core and Anthony the answer to that
is no
okay
the healthy brain and heart pack it
contains a lot of the
nutrients in different forms the core 90
is all liquid concentrates the brain and
heart pack includes the nutrients that
are in the core but it also adds in
additional fatty acids Omega 3 6 and 9
where core focuses on three the core 90
and and core 90 folks for those of you
who are not familiar with that 490 is
the name of a pack that you can find at
dailywithdoc.com or get back with the
person that shared this program with you
and it gives the foundation it's like
our our budgeted version of getting the
90 essential nutrients
it's it's it's
how the rain and hard pack has 215
nutrients in it 150 it's a big hammer
what
it's the big hammer oh the big hammer
yeah yeah
nutrients uh 115 of which are from
um fruit and vegetables that have been
dried and extracted and everything like
that added to the core 90. core 90 is
still the core 90 in there
and so you know so when I say I take two
of those a day I'm getting 215 nutrients
twice a day just from those two doses of
the
of the Hildebrand heart pack then I
throw in my two doses of the rebound and
then
it depend on what else is going on okay
well Dr Wally
everything that you take can be
complicated for some but it does not
have to be folks
youngevity has made it simple with the
different packs that they've put
together there's the secret sauces which
many of the things that Dr Wallach adds
on beyond the brain and heart pack we
consider secret sauces those are things
that adding those extra nutrients to
address the depletion that has the daily
classic tablet which is a secret sauce
ultimate daily classes it's a secret
sauce the collagen is a secret sauce the
de-stress is a secret sauce
sweeties sweeties
you know all these things are secret
sauces that were developed and
formulated to address specific health
concerns that have occurred because of
not having them in the diet Dr Wallach
that's correct no more wood ashes
no more wood ashes well we don't have to
eat Ash and Dr Wallach you need to be
going to your next program so thank you
so much again for joining us and if I
can get my co-hosts on here I don't like
to be alone so come join me
I loved all the people that I'm able to
surround myself with and Jill I see your
hand is up did you have a question for
Dr Wallach or a general question
go ahead and unmute yourself I do but if
you want us to go I can ask another day
it was a kind of a simple one for him
okay well yes
um
I was trying to find out what they
recommended for someone who has puffy
eyes all the time under her eyes
oh that's a great question for him
um what I'll do is I've got it saved
here thanks to my amazing co-hosts they
have sent me a message and a screenshot
of it so that we can get to it tomorrow
I got online so it's not
all right no worries thank you Jill
thank you and for those of you who are
watching the replay and you are not
working oh sorry Joe
that's my bad
I love you sister but um
there we go I'm watching the replay
and you have questions and you're not
working with somebody else we have a
whole team of certified holistic health
coaches that are here to assist you in
making sure that you get the information
knowledge and also the solutions
to addressing health
you can go to daily withdoc.com use that
contact us or we do have that call team
standing by
855-949-3377 and again this is for
people that are not already working with
somebody we want to make sure that you
get back with the person who shared this
program with you because they cared
enough
to share this program with you they want
to see you thrive not just barely
survive
or be in pain so until next time my name
is Becca Dukes thank you so much for all
of you that are watching this program
again if you're interested in joining us
on this Crusade use daily withdoc.com
use the contact us and send us a message
and let us know that you are interested
but if somebody I want to be very clear
about this if somebody shared this
program with you get back with them give
them the opportunity
Sherry Browning Roselle and Sanchez
Marilyn fazera spear Farhan Nasir you
are amazing individuals that have joined
me in this and helping to make sure that
this program is a success and I couldn't
do it without you and others so thank
you all for joining us uh and for being
part of my team and until next time
bye for now everybody
oh thanks Bobby
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]